hey youtubers is Charlie so huge news
Daniel Bruhl was just confirmed as one
of the new villains in Captain America 3
so this is gonna be a video about the
top 5 people I think he could be playing
and how that might fit into the other
phase 3 movies Marvel has not confirmed
who he's playing but variety is
reporting that he's going to be a
secondary villain in Captain America but
the main villain of Doctor Strange I
think right away there's like a clear
pic but I'm gonna go through my top 5
picks and then do a breakdown of each
character the big one everyone's talking
about obviously is Red Skull he could be
playing a new version of Red Skull it's
widely believed that Hugo Weaving isn't
gonna return to the Red Skull role like
he's not gonna return to the Marvel
Universe that was a one-off deal for him
but the character Red Skull could
totally come back Daniel Bruhl totally
amazing actor totally think he can pull
it off if you don't believe me just
watch rush he is amazing as niki lauda
he's just an amazing actor in general so
here we go top 5 picks number 5 Doctor
Faustus this is my least likely pick but
Doctor Faustus was associated with Hydra
you can think of him as like an evil
Sigmund Freud which certainly would link
him to the mind gem and what Hydra has
been doing in the events leading up to
age of Ultron he also was a big part of
the death of Captain America comic book
storyline and that's rumored to be part
of the inspiration for Captain America 3
I mean it's Civil War but the death of
Captain America came right after that
don't know how they're gonna address
that in the movie universe I don't
expect Chris Evans to die but it's
totally possible we could see some
elements of that in the movie since
Faustus is a lesser character I think
it's possible that they could use that
character but he might just be in the TV
universe based on the timeline of those
I don't expect a whole lot of huge Hydra
characters in the Netflix series they
were really pounding that on agents of
shield right now number 4 Nicolas Geist
Geist
also has some loose ties to the Doctor
Strange universe he fits a little bit
better into Captain America stories
because he gets tied up with Winter
Soldier in the comics he ended up
getting stuck in a robot exoskeleton
just to keep himself alive that feels
like more of a MODOK type storyline so
that's also why he's towards the bottom
of my list but he is a really big
character that they have not used in the
movie universe yet there was an art
during Marvel's heroic age during those
comic
where he tried to remake the world in
hydras image using a lot of mystical
artifacts along with blood from Thor and
a lot of the other more mythical
characters from the Marvel Universe that
feels like more of a reality gem thing
and they kind of did that during
guardians of the galaxy so again much
less likely than some of my other picks
number three Baron Zemo here we're
starting to get to some of the more
likely characters Baron Zemo one of the
biggest characters in the Marvel
Universe underneath Red Skull as well as
Baron von Strucker he's mostly known for
masters of evil I would totally love it
if they do that in the movies thus far
we've only seen Hydra characters we
haven't seen an evil version of The
Avengers yet it will be pretty badass to
see a super villain team-up in a Captain
America movie and he's a character
that's big enough to be one of the
current heads of Hydra
they actually mentioned the heads of
Hydra on agents of shield this week
right now the only ones that we know are
confirmed heads are fair and blonde
Strucker as well as dr. Whitehall Zemo
isn't a character that the movies have
introduced yet so that means that he's
still alive
somewhere floating around the comics
have used him so much that at some point
he's going to have to be in one of the
movies at least in some way just the
other thing that makes him slightly less
likely you know then my top two picks
are the fact that there are better
candidates that are both Hydra
characters and big Doctor Strange
villains Simo has always been more of a
Captain America villain than a Doctor
Strange villain so he'd be a likely
candidate for the main villain of
Captain America 3 and Daniel Bruhl the
character that I'm talking about is
supposed to be the minor villain of
Captain America 3 in the main villain of
Doctor Strange which is kind of funny
which means we have to set our sights a
little bit lower number 2 red skull just
to explain why red skull is my number 2
pick and not my number one pick is
because I just I don't feel like this is
a slam-dunk I do think that we'll see
Red Skull again
he'll totally appear in a future Captain
America movie at some point but I think
because Hugo Weaving is contract is kind
of up in the air and they're not sure if
he's ever gonna come back to play him
they're just kind of leaving him on the
side I've seen a lot of you ask
questions about how he's still alive
what happened to him at the end of the
first Captain America movie just
remember this the tesseract is the space
gem it teleports matter too you know who
knows where so he's floating
in space for all we know and the thing
that a lot of big creators talk about
are that supervillains like the epic
villains never truly die like they'll
never truly go away there's no final
death the other strike against him is
that he's almost too big of a character
to be the lesser villain of a Captain
America movie I feel like any movie he
stepped into he would automatically
become the big villain of and my number
one pick the pretty obvious choice Baron
Mordo the reason I think Baron Mordo is
the best pick is because he's not quite
as powerful or as famous or infamous as
say Red Skull or some of the other big
huge Marvel villains but he is one of
the biggest Doctor Strange villains if
not the main Doctor Strange villain so
if variety is right and Daniel Bruhl is
playing a character that'll be a lesser
villain in Captain America but the main
villain in Doctor Strange I feel like
it's a pretty clear pick Baron Mordo all
the way it'd be totally awesome to see
Dormammu as the main villain of a Doctor
Strange movie but since he's a godly
demonic construct I feel like it's just
a little too outlandish for a first
movie outing the villain needs to be a
physical person that you could punch
with your fists if you needed to not
that Doctor Strange is gonna be that
kind of movie but just think about it
this way Daniel Bruhl can't wait to see
him as a villain and Captain America but
imagine he gets his hands on the soul
gem at the end of that movie gains the
power he needs to become the big bad in
Doctor Strange and then that movie
becomes the battle for the soul gem
that's just a theory but I feel like
it's the most plausible one of all these
picks regardless of whether or not the
soul gem is involved and just the idea
of Daniel Bruhl against Benedict
Cumberbatch just sounds so amazing let
me know though which of these guys do
you think he's playing or do you think
he's playing someone else just remember
he can be a minor villain in Captain
America but he has to be the main
villain in Doctor Strange if you've ever
heard the term Big Bad it's actually
something from Joss Whedon's Buffy
that's when the term was coined
it's where normal villain is typically
outmatched by the heroes in this case
Captain America the Avengers Doctor
Strange somehow they obtain knowledge an
item some sort of power making them an
insurmountable threat for the heroes
that's why they're called the big bad
you know bad two big bad like normally
the Red Skull is a huge threat but
imagine him with
power of the tesseract of all the things
in the Marvel Universe that can make a
normal villain almost invincible
I think the infinity gems are the best
pick regardless of what goes on in
Captain America 3
I think Doctor Strange will feature the
soul gem it just seems like a natural
fit for that kind of story
the soul is a much more mystical idea
than what the movies have dealt with so
far Doctor Strange is opening that up
still a whole lot more really big phase
3 stuff to talk about so my next video
will probably be an age of Ultron video
about Ultron stories feel free to make
any requests in the comments though if
there are any specific phase 3 Marvel
movie videos you want to talk about
right now the next ones on my list after
age of Ultron are Black Panther and
Captain Marvel I've already done videos
for some of the other ones like Thor 3
Inhumans Doctor Strange so I'll have
links for those in the description if
you want to learn more about those
movies while you wait for more Marvel
bonus videos you can click here to learn
more about for three Ragnarok and you
can click here to learn more about the
other phase 3 movies thank you so much
for watching now let's all high five and
I will see you guys tomorrow